- [Instructor] Let's say
that we have some number a
and to that we are going
to add some number b
and that sum is going to be equal to c.
Let's say that we're also told
that both a and b are irrational.
Irrational.
So based on the information
that I've given you,
a and b are both irrational.
Is their sum, c, is that going
to be rational or irrational?
I encourage you to pause the video
and try to answer that on your own.
I'm guessing that you might have struggled
with this a little bit
because the answer is
that we actually don't know.
It depends on what irrational
numbers a and b actually are.
What do I mean by that?
Well, I can pick two irrational numbers
where their sum actually
is going to be rational.
What do I mean?
Well what if a is equal to pi
and b is equal to one minus pi?
Now both of these are irrational numbers.
Pi is irrational and one minus
pi, whatever this value is,
this is irrational as well.
But if we add these two things together,
if we add pi plus one minus pi,
one minus pi, well these are gonna add up
to be equal to one,
which is clearly going
to be a rational number.
So we were able to find one scenario
in which we added two irrationals
and the sum gives us a rational.
In general you could do this trick
with any irrational number.
Instead of pi you could've had
square root of two plus one
minus the square root of two.
Both of these,
what we have in this
orange color is irrational,
blue color is irrational,
but the sum is going to be rational.
And you could do this,
instead of having one minus,
you could have this as 1/2 minus.
You could have done it a bunch
of different combinations
so that you could end up
with a sum that is rational.
But you could also easily
add two irrational numbers
and still end up with
an irrational number.
For example, if a is pi
and b is pi,
well then their sum is
going to be equal to two pi,
which is still irrational.
Or if you added pi
plus the square root of two,
this is still going to be irrational.
In fact, mathematically
I would just express this
as pi plus the square root of two.
This is some number right over here,
but this is still going to be irrational.
So the big takeaway is
if you're taking the sums
of two irrational numbers
and people don't tell you anything else,
they don't tell you which
specific irrational numbers they are,
you don't know whether their sum
is going to be rational or irrational.
Now let's think about products.
Similar exercise, let's
say we have a times b
is equal to c, ab is equal to c,
a times b is equal to c.
And once again, let's
say someone tells you
that both a and b are irrational.
Pause this video and think about
whether c must be rational, irrational,
or whether we just don't know.
Try to figure out some examples
like we just did when we looked at sums.
Alright, so let's think about,
let's see if we can construct examples
where c ends up being rational.
Well one thing, as you
can tell I like to use pi,
pi might be my favorite irrational number.
If a was one over pi
and b is pi,
well, what's their product going to be?
Well, their product is going
to be one over pi times pi,
that's just going to be pi
over pi, which is equal to one.
Here we got a situation where
the product of two irrationals
became, or is, rational.
But what if I were to multiply,
and in general you could this
with a lot of irrational numbers,
one over square root of two
times the square of two,
that would be one.
What if instead I had pi times pi?
Pi times pi, that you could
just write as pi squared,
and pi squared is still
going to be irrational.
This is irrational, irrational.
It isn't even always the case
that if you multiply the
same irrational number,
if you square an irrational number
that it's always going to be irrational.
For example, if I have
square root of two times,
I think you see where this is going,
times the square root of two,
I'm taking the product of
two irrational numbers.
In fact, they're the
same irrational number,
but the square root of two
times the square root of two,
well, that's just going
to be equal to two,
which is clearly a rational number.
So once again, when
you're taking the product
of two irrational numbers,
you don't know whether the product
is going to be rational or irrational
unless someone tells you
the specific numbers.
Whether you're taking the product
or the sum of irrational numbers,
in order to know whether
the resulting number
is irrational or rational,
you need to know something
about what you're taking
the sum or the product of.